we got to find the blue jays at home
they may be homeless this year
and then when they're on the road as the
home team they bat last
that might be their big advantage but uh
buffalo still a possibility
i think baltimore is probably the likely
destination and then you share the
ballpark with the orioles but tom
verducci will know more than i do
baseball network analyst on loan from
mlb
tom good morning uh where are the blue
jays going to end up in your opinion
well my backyard is available it's a
short porch in right field but
i actually think it's a combination of
finding some major league park perhaps
it's baltimore to share
for a short term but they could upgrade
their facility in buffalo that's where i
think it might go
because right now that's their aaa
ballpark and
the lighting there is not up to major
league standards and most of the games
are at night
neither is the clubhouse so they need to
get somebody in there to upgrade the
facility i
imagine that's going to take a couple of
weeks in the meantime
you know you play the games perhaps in
baltimore or you're on the road i
dan i just can't see this team playing
60 games
in 66 days entirely on the road so i
think
probably buffalo with an upgraded
facility
but how did we get to this point tom
toronto doesn't have a home
yeah i mean they were allowed to do
their summer camp there because no
teams were coming in and out from
coronavirus hot spots that was the
concern
of the canadian government and then was
the concern of the
allegheny county commissioners when they
went to or tried to go to pnc park to
share that with the pirates so
there's no guarantee they can get to
camden yards in baltimore they would
need local officials to sign off
on that as well and let's not forget too
if you're sharing a major league
ballpark the parks
already are kind of stretched thin for
social distancing
you're not using one clubhouse now
you're using multiple clubhouses and
kind of ad hoc rooms that are turned
into mini clubhouses
so you'd have to house two teams with 60
players
um so they had maybe have to i don't
know invent some kind of a
auxiliary clubhouses um to accommodate
the jays
it is crazy that here we are today's
opening day
and we don't know where the blue jays
home schedule will take place we don't
know how many playoff teams there are
this year tom
you have to wait long though we'll know
that by this evening before first pitch
but
i think it's a good thing that there's
more discussion going on here listen i
i think the players will sign off on
this think about it then
the expanded postseason from 10 to 16.
that means 156 more players will get to
the postseason
it also means they're 300 million
dollars more in tv money just
this year alone and guaranteed money
going forward
and when owners get guaranteed money
from tv contracts
guess what they pass it on to the
players so
i actually think it's a good thing i
thought i couldn't understand why the
players didn't agree to it a month ago
but there's time very little time to get
it done
in time for this season mlb network's
opening night coverage starts at uh
10 a.m eastern time joining the
broadcast at 4 p.m
also uh on the call for saturday's
pirates cardinals game on mlb network
and uh doing studio stuff i believe is
that
the schedule here for you tom okay
that's the schedule um
mookie betts is deal kind of surprising
uh
well more surprising the timing of it or
the length and the amount of money
yeah i guess the timing damn because in
the middle of a pandemic who's got 365
million dollars sitting around well i
guess the answer is the dodgers but
listen when they made the deal with the
red sox they didn't want to extend him
they gave up
some good young prospects they didn't
want just to rent him for a year and
this year's only 60 games
but i was told that once they had him in
camp in march and especially the last
couple of weeks here in summer camp
they were blown away by how good this
guy is now it's not exactly breaking
news that mookie betts is a really good
player
but i think it's different when you have
the player in your clubhouse every day
and they start they were blown away by
how good this guy is how good he is
around teammates the positive attitude
every day
so the fact that they gave up a lot to
get him but really fell in love with
having him on hand
this was a no-brainer don't forget they
tried to give 300 million
plus to garrett cole he had his heart
kind of set on the yankees
so i know the dodgers at this point
under andrew friedman had not given out
a 100 million dollar deal
it was a matter of which guy was best
first it was call but once it was not
call
then it was mookie and listen i think
it's a great buy forget about the back
end of the deal you judge a deal to me
on are you buying the prime years of a
player and how good is he right now
and as i said he's one of the top five
players and that team is
loaded then for now and for the
foreseeable future
but if you're a red sox fan how do you
feel about this oh
it hurts man listen this guy was a fifth
round draft pick he wasn't exactly like
this
you know can't miss superstar come out
of high school
homegrown star who's just a likable
player he's one of my favorite players
to watch
play the game of baseball he should have
played his entire career in a red sox
uniform
because of how good he is and what a
good person he is but listen they made a
bit of a run to try to extend him they
didn't get the vibes that it was going
to happen i think he made it clear he
wanted to go to free agency
and then you can't disregard the issue
the competitive balance tax
the red sox had an opportunity to reset
that tax rate they've done that this
year with the
the trade of price and bets but as a red
sox fan it's gonna hurt
it's going to hurt more because this red
this dodger team
they'll be watching mookie in the
playoffs for years to come
we're talking to tom vernucci mlb
network analyst you uh we're the first
on the bandwagon i believe
of watch out for tampa as maybe the team
to beat in the american league
feels like there's more competitors in
the american link than the national
league i feel like it's
dodgers nationals and then you can throw
in
oakland the yankees um who else am i
missing out on
uh oh houston is there yeah wins
the twins are still really your team i
think you're right there's probably
the group of elite teams in the american
league is probably bigger
than in the national league i think to
me the dodgers are clearly the best team
in the national league no disrespect to
the nationals who i think would be a
handful if they get in again
because remember last year they were
10-0 when scherzer and strasberg started
so they could do the same mo in the
postseason environment
don't sleep on the braves they're still
a really good team but i i do think the
american league is deeper i think the
race between the yankees and rays comes
down to the 10 games head to head
between those
two teams um and i do think the a's are
you know
they don't get a lot of attention dan
but if you asked billy bean two or three
years ago he would tell you that 2020
is the year that they were pointing to
the chapman olsen group and they'd be
all ready with major league service time
and proven players at this point
young pitchers look really good um the
team i'm curious about is chicago white
sox
because i know everybody's saying in a
short season anything can happen it's
not entirely true i mean the orioles are
not going to the playoffs the marlins
are not going to the playoffs even in a
15-game season but in a 60-game season
the white sox i think have a
very high ceiling they're one of these
teams that have
a basement and a ceiling and it'd be
very fascinating to see how it plays out
to me white socks reds
diamondbacks they're kind of in that
group where they could be a lot better
than people think
yeah i've heard about the the reds and
the white sox and watching the white sox
against the cubs the other night and you
start to look at the lineup
and the pitching and then hey
a short season 60 game sprint and and
you're right you get hot
at the right time and uh we're gonna
have at least one surprise team that
gets in there it feels like
i'm also curious uh if you win the cy
young this year
if jacob degrom wins the cy young does
that say young
count just the way the previous two did
um yeah it does and you do get the
trophy
but you have to keep it in your desk you
can't hang on the wall
but he could go six and two and win the
cy young
yeah i mean listen these guys are only
to get 11 or 12 starts so
six or seven wins and you know eura have
won something
yeah i mean somebody's going to win the
mvp somebody's going to win the sigh
i actually think there's a good chance
that someone is going to have an era
below 1.12 of course that's bob gibson's
record
now it won't be a record in a 60 game
season but i think you're more likely to
see that than somebody hitting 400.
nobody's going to hit 400 the game's
just the way it's played now nobody hits
for a high average pitching's too good
but i can name you five guys i think
could have under a one one
two era over 10 or 11 starts i went back
i didn't realize that ichiro
over a 60 game span hit i think 460
back in the early 2000s is that does
that sound right
it is it's crazy that was the year he
had uh what 262 hits
but if you just go by the first 60 games
of the season nobody has hit 400 over
the first 60 games which doesn't sound
like a whole lot
since chipper jones and knows more than
a decade ago you know i remember talking
to
uh cody bellinger last year when he got
off to that great start and he was just
under 400
by the two-month mark and he said
nobody's hitting 400. he said i feel
like i hit out of my mind and i'd go one
for three and my average
would go down three points ah
well we're ready to play baseball oh do
you have to wear a mask at first base
does the first baseman have to wear a
mask
uh he does not it's an option you could
i mean there will some be some players
divi gregorius will play with one
uh clint frazier the yankees but it's
not mandatory
if i go to first base and i'm leading
off that they're
they're not invoking any social
distancing there right
no because that's by cdc guidelines not
literally considered close contact
because you are
outdoors um the minimum period to be
considered close contact i think is 15
minutes
at least in terms of if you are positive
and when they do the contact tracing did
you have contact with someone for 15
minutes
okay so in that brief period outdoors
it's not considered close contact
tom good to talk to you and uh it's nice
that i'm not peppering you with
questions about what baseball's doing
wrong that we have
we think the start of a baseball season
yeah i think it could be a lot of fun
then i really do if we play through the
season september we'll have more
meaningful games than ever before
especially if ten teams or eight teams
in each league go to the postseason
it could be a wild scramble so let's
let's hope we get to uh the end of
october
with safe and sound thank you tom that's
tom perducci mlb network analyst
opening night coverage starts at 10 a.m
eastern and tom joining the broadcast at
four also part of the call for
saturday's pirates cardinals game on mlb
network